[Music]
welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn I'm going to be your host
first I'd like to introduce you to our
our team and coming from California bya
Skype is Pastor James
raferty welcome hey JD Shelly Daniel it
is so good to be with you all via modern
technology looking forward to our Bible
Q&A today you know it just amazes me
just to time just thinking about this
you were here just a day or two ago now
you're there for a day then you're back
here the same day the Miracles of
technology and I remember the story goes
that whenever my grandfather went to
Texas it was in a covered wagon MH wow
wow wow boy have we come a long ways
long ways wow Pastor Daniel morone
welcome thank you so much for having me
looking forward to it amen and my
precious sister Shelley Quinn how are
you do you're going to confuse people
brother Quinn I'm J's wife we just want
to thank you so much for sending in your
questions so that we get this
opportunity to study with you and we
learn as we do so thank you amen there's
three ways for you to send your
questions into US number one is if you
would like to text it's
618 228 397
75 if you would like to send it by email
it's Bible
QA
3abn.org
again probably about 20 minutes but
anyway that's the three ways let's open
up by having prayer fathers we come to
you today in the name of Jesus thank you
for this wonderful opportunity that
you've given us Lord to share what's in
your book lord your words your thoughts
father we just ask Lord that all those
that are hearing father that their
questions will be a answered and father
that you will be with each person here
and father that your words will come out
of their mouths we love you and we thank
you we ask this in the name of Jesus
amen amen amen amen amen we've got 12
questions and uh most of them are three
minute questions there's a couple each
one of them get a 4minute question and
I'm going to go in order with Pastor
James
Pastor Daniel and
Shelly number one Pastor James second
Thessalonians 2:11 says that God will
send strong delusions in the last days
why will go why will God send strong
delusions since Satan is deceiving
people anyway and this is from Tammy in
Kansas well Tammy that's an important
question let's look at what the Bible
teaches on the subject as a whole so
that we can better understand the text
in question in the Book of Romans Paul
who is the same inspired author of 2
Thessalonians takes up a prophecy that
Likens Christ to a stumbling block to
those who do not receive him it's in
Romans chapter 9: 32 and 33 here's what
the text says for they stumbled at that
stumbling Stone as it is written behold
I lay in Zion a stumbling Stone a rock
of off fense and whosoever believeth on
him shall not be ashamed so the Greek
word for stumbling Stone means an
occasion of
apostasy and so Jesus became a stumbling
block or an occasion of apostasy when he
was actually trying to save people from
apostasy in fact a stumbling block is
something that the Bible warns Believers
not to become in Romans 414 and: 13 and
in 1 Corinthians 88:9 so Jesus Christ
became something the Bible says we
shouldn't become to those who refuse to
receive him the Jews would not received
the truth or the love of it and so
Christ became a stumbling block and in
this way truth Jesus becomes a stumbling
block on occasion of apostasy when it is
rejected here's a simple outline number
one God sends light to every man John 1
ver9 number two man makes a choice to
accept or reject that light John 3: 19
and number three if rejected the light
that is sent to us becomes Darkness or a
stumbling block or an occasion of
apostasy and you can find that in Luke
1:35 concerning Christ so God is not
sending strong delution God is sending
light he's sending truth he's sending
the gospel and if men choose not to
receive that truth and the love of that
truth the very light that God sends then
becomes a snare a stumbling block an
occasion of apostasy or strong delusion
the devil leads people who choose to
reject truth to beared by the very idea
of the truth and then that very truth
becomes a stumbling Blocker in of
apostasy just to make this as clear as
possible let's illustrate it have you
ever shared Bible truth with someone who
had never heard it before they're open
they're even convicted and possibly are
going to become a believer in the truth
and then they go to their Pastor priest
or a friend or someone they respect and
they hear something completely different
like oh that old Sabbath that was for
the Jews not the Christians or that law
was nailed to the cross or everyone
knows you go to heaven when you die and
this happens all the time
take it for me as someone who's done a
lot of evangelism Bible study and and
here's the kicker people who reject the
truth really start to believe the lie
they even preach it and rail against
anyone who accepts the Bible truth that
Sabbath was for the Jews death is like
sleep that's sleep heresy uh Soul sleep
heresy obedience to the law that's
legalism so the truth itself becomes a
delusion because they receive not the
love of it they may have been open to
the truth at one time but by not
receiving and loving the truth itself
that truth becomes their enemy just like
the Jews saw Jesus as beels above
himself just so Truth for those who
reject it becomes a strong delusion and
accepting the deceptions of Satan in
place of Bible truth leaves us in a
place where the truth itself becomes a
delusion to us when we refuse to receive
the love of the truth we leave ourselves
wide open for the deceptions of Satan so
in closing consider these words of
Christ these are from Matthew chapter 6:
22 and
23 in the light excuse me the light of
the body is the eye if therefore thine
eye be single thy whole body shall be
full of light but if thine eye be evil
thy whole body shall be full of Darkness
if therefore the light that is in you be
Darkness how great is that Darkness
accept the truth and the love of the
truth and you will not be deceived with
a strong delusion and think that that
truth is error great explanation
thank you good Daniel are there any
texts in the Bible that talk about
working too much or overworking
IE Workaholics this is from Bridget in
Michigan well that's a great question
there Bridget you know the Bible does
talk about work about working and
resting you God himself ended his work
and he rested on the seventh day
according to Genesis chapter 2 and verse
two
Exodus 20:9 says six days shalt thou
labor and do all thy work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
thy God in it Thou shalt not do any
work Ecclesiastes 3 says to everything
there is a season and a time to every
purpose under the heaven so I believe we
can add time to work and a time to
refrain from work verse 13 says and also
that every man should eat and drink and
enjoy the good of all his labor it is
the gift of God enjoyment or contentment
comes from God it's it's his gift to you
you know you can work and work and if
you're never satisfied what good is it
Paul said that he had learned to be
content in whatsoever State he was found
that's in Philippians
4:11 and he told the Corinthians in 1
Corinthians
9:2 and every man that striveth for the
Mastery is temperent in all things so
even when it comes to working for
Jesus we find Jesus telling his
disciples to Come Ye yourselves apart
into a desert place and rest a while
Ecclesiastes 4:8 this maybe sounds like
a workaholic that U Solomon is talking
about he says there is one alone and
there is not a second yay he hath
neither child nor brother yet is there
no end end of all his labor neither is
his eye satisfied with riches neither
saith he for whom do I do I labor and
beve my soul of
good you know this is also vanity yeah
it is sore
travail so again it sounds like somebody
that might be a
workaholic when this was King Solomon
who was known for his wisdom he said it
was vanity or emptiness transitory and
unsatisfactory so I believe that God's
word does talk about working too much
thank you for the question amen and it's
hard to strike the balance sometimes
true Shelly your question yes the Book
of Proverbs advises us that above all
else we should guard our hearts how do
we guard our heart could you illustrate
with some Bible verses please and this
is from Ben and morus in East Africa
Ben I love your heart because that's it
shows you're concerned about this you're
talking about Proverbs 4:23 and first
let's define what the heart is in
scripture this is the will the character
of man it's your thoughts your emotions
your desires and your intentions and
there's a lot of good clues in context
we're going to begin with proverbs 4
verse 20 we're going to read this
scripture in context my son pay
attention to what I say listen closely
to my words do not let them out of your
sight keep them within your heart for
they are life to those who find them and
health to a man's whole body so the word
of God is life to you you've got to if
you're going to guard your heart we'll
see you got to fill your mind with God's
word and then he says verse 23 Above All
Else guard your heart for it is the
Wellspring of Life put now he's going to
show us how to do that put away
perversity from your mouth that's one
way to guard your heart Jesus said that
a man brings out of The Treasure of his
heart a good man brings good things
forward but the evil man brings forth
evil and he says um put away perversity
from your mouth keep corrupt talk from
your lips that's a way to guard your
heart let your eyes look straight ahead
make a covenant with your eyes not to
look on something evil and as job did he
says um fix your gaze directly before
you make level paths for your feet and
that's what I pray all the time the Lord
will make a level path for my feet take
only ways that are firm that's following
the Lord's way in his path of Life do
not swerve to the right right or to the
left keep your foot from Evil so if you
want to guard your heart every day pray
to be filled with the Holy Spirit I pray
Psalm 51:10 where David said create in
me a clean heart oh God renew a
steadfast spirit for me do not take your
holy spirit away from me and let me
don't cast me away from your presence so
pray only God can create a clean heart
that word is barah it's a word that's
only used of God in the beginning God
barah created the heavens in the earth
it's to to bring something out of
nothing Psalm 119 verse 11 get into his
word the psalmist said your word I have
hidden in my heart that I might not sin
against you Romans 8 excuse me Romans 10
8-10 confess his word Paul calls it the
word of faith he says it's in your mouth
and in your heart you confess that the
Lord Jesus is Christ and you will
believe Matthew 1234 and 35 uh is where
Jesus said out of the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks so you're either
going to bring forth good or
evil pray Philippians
46-7 if you want to guard your heart you
got to pray he says be anxious for
nothing but in everything by prayer and
supplication with Thanksgiving let your
request be made known to God and the
peace of God which surpasses all
understanding will guard your hearts and
Minds through Christ Jesus I always ask
when I'm asking to be filled with the
Holy Spirit I ask the Lord pour your
love into my heart Romans 55 says that
it is the Holy Spirit who shed
sheds God's love abroad into our heart
and the most important thing is Matthew
2237 through 40 where Jesus said you've
got to love the Lord your God with all
of your heart soul mind and strength
love your neighbor as yourself we can
only do that by the power of the holy
spirit amen very well put amen Pastor
James second question the Bible says
that at the end times we will be judged
by our works why does it say that when I
was under the impression that we are
saved by grace not by works and yet we
will be judged by our works and this is
from Ed in
California Ed in California thank you Ed
for that opportunity to this opportunity
to answer the your question the address
address the topic of grace and works uh
and I'm here in California with you
somewhere from a at least from a
Biblical perspective we can see that yes
we are saved by grace and yes we are
judged by works the Bible's very clear
on that in fact Ephesians chapter 2
there famous verses in uh Ephesians
chapter 2 veres 8-10 uh makes it very
clear that we're saved by our by Grace
let's just take a look at these verses
for by Grace you're saved through faith
and that not of yourselves it is the
gift of God not of Works lest any man
should boast so there we go we're saved
by grace we're not saved by works in
fact not of Works lest any man should
boast but then it goes on in verse 10 to
say for we are his workmanship created
in Christ Jesus unto good works which
God has before ordained that we should
walk in them so if we're saved by grace
through faith why then are we judged by
our works well while Works do not save
us they testify to the authenticity of
our salvation by grace through faith in
other words salvation by grace through
faith produces good works that God has
ordained that we should walk in them
according to verse 10 of Ephesians 2 so
unfortunately some people have come into
God's church and taken upon themselves a
different idea about the grace of God
that saves us they've turned it into a
license to sin now we read about this in
many passages in the Bible but I think
the one in Jude uh verses 3 and 4 is the
clearest it says here in Jude 3 and 4
dear friends I'm reading from the NIV
although I was very eager to write to
you about the salvation we share I felt
compelled to write to you in urge you to
contend for the faith that was once
delivered and trusted to the holy people
for certain
individuals uh have whose condemnation
was written about long ago have secretly
slipped in among you these are ungodly
people who pervert the grace of God and
turn it into a license to for immorality
and deny Jesus Christ Our Lord and
Savior so Four Points here we're urged
to contend for the faith because
individuals were written about long ago
who would secretly slip into the church
ungodly number three who's would pervert
God's grace turn it into a licis for
immorality and in doing this number four
they deny Jesus Christ so God deals with
this crisis of these people secretly
slipping in among us professing to be
saved by grace but turning Grace into a
license to sin or cheap Grace we call it
God does this by having a judgment an
investigative judgment and he's the one
that can determine who are the true and
the false and so this judgment by our
works which are evidence of our being
saved by grace through faith is what God
sets up in order to clarify this and we
can read about the importance of the
works and obeying God's law in verses
other verses like Romans
3:31 and Romans 61 and2 Galatians 56
James chapter 2 also talks about the
importance of our works being produced
by our uh faith in Jesus Christ uh and
the Grace by which we're saved uh so
that is the reason why we're saved saved
by grace but with judg by works good
answer Pastor Daniel if God died for our
sins and bought back the world from
Satan why do we choose to sin first
rather than to do good first this is
from Tony and
Canada wow it doesn't make sense there
does it
Tony so it's a great question you know I
believe Paul addresses this in Romans
chapter 7 so in the first part of
chapter 7 Paul addresses being read
released from the law by using the
illustration of the law of marriage
where if your spouse dies when you then
you aren't committing adultery if you
marry another and we become dead to this
law by the body or death of Christ that
we should be married to another even to
him who is raised from the dead that we
should bring forth fruit unto God in the
second section of this chapter Paul
establishes that the law is not sin and
actually that is a positive thing that
we wouldn't know what sin was if we
didn't have the
law then in coming to verse 14 we read
for we know that the law is spiritual
but I am carnal sold under sin so when
Adam chose to be selfish and go against
God's command to not eat the fruit we
were all put into the bondage to sin God
created Adam sinless or selfless and
then he chose to be selfish so that's a
really a big deal actually man's nature
was totally compromised he went from
selflessness to selfishness did you ever
notice that the first time you did
something it was hard to go against your
conscience but the next time it was
easier our Natures are now selfish our
flesh is corrupt so then in verse 15 we
see Paul describing the struggle that
Tony's referring to in this question
regarding our bent or default being sin
or selfish and that's versus good or
selflessness
here's where Paul is pointing us to the
spiritual battle using our power of
choice to think or believe what we want
to that's in verses 22 to 24 Paul brings
out these two contrasting laws
selfishness and
selflessness God's law is based on
Selfless Love Paul describes it as the
law of God after the inward
man then in verse 23 he differentiates
this law as in my members
Waring against the law of his mind
that's verse 24 it shows his desperation
when he cries out who's going to be able
to deliver me from this body of death
and he gives us the answer and he
summarizes these two laws that are with
us while we are in these mortal bodies
of
sin Adam became selfish when he made his
choice and here's a side note only Jesus
lived a totally selfless life in this
human flesh amen that he was and it had
degenerated for several thousand years
before Adam's original selfless nature
he's the only one who chose
selflessness in every decision that he
ever made amen so you and I can live
this life of selflessness only as we
look away from ourselves unto Jesus who
is totally this totally selfless human
being this is how we become changed or
put in another way by looking unto Jesus
we have the power to break from our
default characters of sin or selfishness
we become new creatures one decision at
a time evidently this war between Christ
and Satan actually includes being able
to withstand Satan's darts of Temptation
in our human flesh and that's through
the power of God's love and grace he
says to work out your own salvation with
fear and trembling for it is God who
worketh in you both to Will and to do of
his good pleasure and he does that while
we're in these human bodies thank you
again for that question amen am good
answer good answer
Shelly if we have free will and we all
have a choice to make between good and
evil and history shows that lucier and
the third of the Angels along with Adam
and Eve sinned and nobody is righteous
then how will sin be forever ended when
the new Heaven and Earth are made and we
have been Resurrection to eternal life
how will sin never enter even one
Resurrection resurrected person's
thought or mind again will we no longer
have free will and this is from Britany
in West Virginia Britany this is such a
great question and I want to point you
first to naam 1:9 where it says God will
make an utter end of sin and affliction
will not rise up a second time when we
look at the last two chapters of the
Bible Revelation 21 and revelation
22 they provide clear evidence that
there will be no sinners in heaven there
will be no sin in heaven and no sin in
the Earth for eternity future the former
things have passed away the curse of sin
which is death has passed away no
corruptable children of God will be in
heaven
they will have direct access to God so 1
Corinthians 15:
52-54 says that in a moment in the
twinkling of an eye at the sound of the
Trump the dead are raised Incorruptible
we are completely transformed for this
corruptible must put on incorruption
this Mortal must put on
immortality Philippians 1:6 one of my
favorite promises he who has begun a
good work work in you will complete it
until the day of Christ Jesus right up
to the time of his return he's
developing that good work and he's
perfecting us and bringing it into full
completion in us first John 3:2 says we
know that when he is revealed we shall
be like him
Hallelujah we'll see him as he is and
here's Britney the big thing is the
power of Christ and our Union with him
will keep us
faultless Jude 24 and 25 two of my
favorite verses Jude only has one
chapter so this is verses 24 and 25 and
it says now to him who is able to keep
you from stumbling and to present you
faultless before the presence of his
glory with exceeding joy to God our
savior who alone is unique who alone is
wise be glory and Majesty dominion and
power both now and forever will we have
a free will in heaven yes we but we will
be perfected we will be kept by his
power we won't have this Fallen nature
that you were talking about you know
where Galatians 5:17 says the spirit
Wars against the flesh that war will be
over and with because we've seen the
effects of sin we will serve the Lord
with joy and gladness with our Free Will
amen very well put amen once again I
just want to throw a reminder out there
so if you want to send your questions in
there's one of three ways number one if
you want to text 618 228 3975
if you'd like to email your questions
Bible QA
3abn.org
in the NIV such as Matthew
17:21 Luke 17:36
Mark
7:16 Mark 15:28 and more is the NIV a
good Bible translation to read even with
the missing Bible text and this is from
Anthony in
Ohio thank you Anthony for your question
uh just to answer quickly yes the NV can
be a good bible to read uh but I would
not recommend it as a study Bible the
reason those texts are missing is
because the NIV and most modern versions
are based on a different set of
manuscripts than the
KJV or the new KJV so I use the NIV and
many other versions of the Bible um but
my in my Bible study my preaching Bible
my teaching Bible my anchor Bible is the
good old
KJV now having said that the Bible uh
also identifies two extremes that we can
go to and we can apply this in principle
to this uh question about Bible version
Isaiah 30:21 says you will hear a voice
behind you saying this is the way walk
you in it when you turn to the left or
when you turn to the right so there's
two Extremes in relation to versions of
the Bible one extreme is the KJV only
and all the the Bible versions are taboo
don't use them don't listen to them
don't even call them a Bible and then of
course the second extreme would be Bible
verses don't matter they're all good as
long as we're reading the Bible it
doesn't matter what version we read now
somewhere between these two extremes we
can find balance and I think it's uh
there's a lot of wiggle room in this in
between place for example we need to
know that there are as you noted in your
question many verses missing from the
NIV and other modern versions of the
Bible there are also some added phrases
and words that have absolutely no
support in the Bible manuscripts like
Sunday has been added to Revelation 1:1
in at least nine modern versions of the
Bible post 2020 and then in Mark 7:19 an
entire phrase has been added making
Jesus say something about unclean meats
that he never said so we need to be
aware of those changes we need to
understand the history of the Bible we
need to make sure that that we have a
good old King James virsion Bible in our
library for comparison and then there
are well there are many other words that
are different in the NIV or modern
versions of the Bible and again we just
need to be aware of those differences
right we need to get educated about
those differences and there's some good
little tracks and materials you can get
about Bible versions that can help with
that so we can understand what to expect
and not be taken off guard because
sometimes you'll read a different
version of the Bible you say wait a
minute my verse is missing or this word
is different or the whole meaning has
changed well you may have noticed that I
referenced the king or the NIV in the
last question that I covered you see I
try to look at as many versions of the
Bible as I can that makes the verse
clear and the NIV made Jude 3 and 4 the
clearest in relationship to answering
that question so make sure you have a
KJV in your library the text is recept
this is what it's based on it's very
reliable the manuscripts are reliable
there were 47 translators some of the
best Scholars ever that that translated
the KJV and then uh even though it may
be more difficult to understand uh get
other Bibles and compare and then you
can you can get an understanding of the
text as you compare these different
versions of the Bible because uh there's
there's difficult words from the KJV and
and even in our language today there's
difficult words so use as many bibles as
you can and have a KJV amen
well Daniel yes sir number three can you
explain Exodus 4 24-
26 this is from Annabelle in the United
Kingdom all right Annabelle thanks for
that question you know these verses are
kind of puzzling when you first first
look at them
let me read them and it came to pass by
the way in the Inn that the Lord met him
and sought to kill him then Zapora took
a sharp Stone and cut off the foreskin
of her son and cast it at his feet and
said surely a bloody husband art thou to
me so he let him
go then she said a bloody husband Thou
Art because of the
circumcision you know that now the rest
of our viewing audience
may be asking what does this have to do
with the price of potatoes meaning what
is that that does this make any sense
what are we talking about
anyway if you back up a couple of
chapters here in the book of Exodus we
recall Moses fleeing to Midian after
killing that Egyptian Taskmaster back in
Egypt and he meets Jethro a priest in
Midian and he gets employment as a
Shepherd for him then Jethro gives him
his daughter Zapora for his wife and
Moses settles down in Midian for 40
years then from a burning bush God calls
Moses to go back to Egypt and then tell
pharaoh to let God's people go well
Moses is reluctant he and God go back
and forth Moses giving an excuse why
he's not the right man for the job and
then God coming back with a remedy for
Moses's excuses until finally Moses
gives in and he's heading back to Egypt
with his wife and his two
sons and here's where we come to this
intriguing scenario found in chap
Genesis chapter
4 Moses stops at an end I mean Exodus
Moses stops at an end where God starts
choking him I'm not sure if that's
exactly what he was doing but not you
know what but it says he was trying to
kill him and she sees that and zapor
recognizes that it's God who is trying
to kill her husband and she possibly
kept Moses from circumcising one of
their sons maybe she watched Moses
circumcise their firstborn and then she
felt sorry for him and kept Moses from
circumcising their second son you know
she wasn't raised with this custom she
knew exactly what needed to be done for
God to spare her husband you know they
may have had several discussions
regarding God's specific command found
in Genesis 17 and: 13 and 14 which says
he that is born Bor in thy house and he
that is bought with money thy money must
needs be circumcised and my Covenant
shall be in your flesh for an
Everlasting Covenant and the
uncircumcised Man Child whose flesh of
his foreskin is not circumcised that
Soul shall be cut off from his people he
hath broken my
Covenant so Moses would not have had the
divine power to carry out God's Mission
while he was holding on to any direct
Disobedience of God's command and that's
the same for us if we hold on to
something that we know is separating us
from God it weakens our witness amen
amen amen it's a tough
question Shelly yes number three I
understand Revelation
14:10 but does verse 11 mean people who
worship the Beast will be tormented
without ceasing in Hell Fire I'd hate to
think of that and this is from Marv in
South Carolina Maran this is the third
Angel's message I'm going to read real
quickly so that people can relate in
Revelation 1499-1
the third Angel follow sing with a loud
voice if anyone worships the beast in
His image receives his mark on his
forehead or on his hand he shall himself
drink the wine of the wrath of God which
is poured out full strength into the C
cup of his indignation and he shall be
tormented with fire and brimstone before
in the presence of the Holy Angels in
the presence of the lamb now you said
you understand that part your question
is verse 11 and the smoke of their
torment ascends forever and ever and
they have no rest day or night who
worshiped the beast in His image and
whoever receives the mark of his name
boy this used to confuse me so much and
through a a lot of study what I've
learned the words Everlasting Eternal
and
forever have no absolute meaning of
their own they are relative terms they
their
definition depends on who they are
describing it is relative to who they
are describing let me give you an
example of a relative word tall the
Statue of Liberty is 3 5T tall a
chihuahua puppy may be 5 in tall so tall
is a relative word when forever Eternal
or uh
Everlasting is used describing the Lord
they pick up his infinite existence and
that's what they mean but when forever
Eternal or or uh Everlasting is used in
relationship to Mortal hum uh
Humanity these mean as long as the thing
either the humanity or something that is
perishable what they mean is they just
reflect the temporary nature and it's as
long as the person or thing exists let
me give you two quick examples Jude
verse 7 there's only one chapter Jude
verse 7 Sodom and gamorra were set forth
as an example
suffering the Vengeance of Eternal fire
are they on fire today no but the
results of the fire were Eternal the the
fire this eternal fire completed its
work and it destroyed Sodom and gomorra
they perished and no longer burned 1
Samuel chapter 1 and verse 22 Samuel was
to live in the Tabernacle of the Lord
forever quote unquote he lived there for
the duration of his life so the smoke
smoke of their torment that is ascending
forever and ever is just as long as it
takes for the perishing of Hell Fire the
fire is not quenched until it finishes
its work and those Sinners perish
eternally amen well well
stated Pastor James James your last
question can you help me understand the
days mentioned in Daniel 12
vers 11 and 12 and this is from Marvel
in
Zambia great question Marvel thank you
for that question you're referring to
Daniel 1211 and 12 that from the time
that the daily sacrifice shall be taken
away and the Abomination that maketh
deset set up there shall be 1,290 days
blessed is he that Waits and comes to
1,300 35 days now these verses are
referring to the prophecy given in
Daniel 11 first we need to understand
how this prophecy fits into the historic
rise of this desolating power we want to
recognize that the little Horn of Daniel
is making two specific attacks in Daniel
chapter 7 he is attacking God's law
verse 25 and in Daniel chapter 8 he is
attacking the sanctuary or the mediation
of Jesus Christ in the Heavenly
sanctuary and that's Daniel 89 12 so it
is this activity against God's Holy
Covenant that is of utmost concern to
the Heavenly Host as they ask the
question how long in Daniel 88:13 how
long is this going to continue and the
truth be cast to the ground the answer
we're told is that it's going to be for
2300 days before that Sanctuary is
cleansed and then this desolating power
is identified in Daniel 11 specifically
beginning in verse 30 as his activity
begins there with its attack against the
Holy Covenant this is again add rest in
verse 30 the ships of chid shall come
against him therefore shall he be
grieved and return and have indignation
against the Holy Covenant so shall he do
he shall even return and have
intelligence with them that forsake the
Holy Covenant an arm shall stand on his
part he shall pollute the sanctuary of
strength there it is again referring
back to Daniel 8 take away the daily
sacrifice place the Abomination that
makes desolate and such as do wickedly
against the Covenant shall he corrupt by
flatteries but the people that know
their God shall be strong into exploits
so you'll know notice here these verses
are specifically speaking about the
Covenant the Covenant the Covenant the
Holy Covenant this is the focal point
and that Holy Covenant is described
simply in Hebrews chap 10: 16-1 17 this
is the Covenant that I will make with
them after those days says the Lord I
will put my laws in their hearts and in
their minds will I write them and their
sins and Lawless Deeds I will remember
no more so God's law and forgiveness the
little horn attacks the law of God
changes it and attacks the Forgiveness
of the ation of Christ this is outlined
in the time prophecy the time prophecy
we're looking at in Daniel uh 12: 11 and
12 are specifically speaking of the 129
the 1335 and the attack against the
sanctuary this began in 508 with the
establishment of a system of counterfeit
mediation and priesthood that replaced
Christ cast his sanctuary in the truth
to the ground it continued to 1798 when
that system received a deadly wound but
then then the the truth of the sanctuary
in heaven was not revealed until 18431
1844 the end of the 1335 years when a
group of people called millerites went
through a tremendous disappointment
thinking that the 2300 day prophecy
would end in the second coming of Christ
to cleanse the Earth or the sanctuary of
the Earth with fire and then finally
realizing the sanctuary was in heaven
the truth had been restored Christ
mediation there had been rediscovered as
as well as the Ten Commandment law and
the people became Seventh Day Adventist
that's who we are so that's a quick
answer to the to the question you can
get more answers if you watch a series
called salvation and symbols and signs
on 3abn amen amen extremely well done
thank you thank you much James Daniel
your fourth question 1 John 2 3 and 4
says Now by this we know that we know
him if we keep his Commandments he who
says I know him and does not keep his
Commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him but I've heard many pastors
saying that you may have been a
wonderful Christian for many years
keeping all the Commandments and still
not know Jesus I've been an S 7th Day
Adventist for several decades and this
got me to thinking how do I know that I
know Jesus and this is from Jonathan in
Nevada well thank you for that question
Jonathan that was a knowing Jesus is the
key there knowing in
Jesus if we go to chapter 5 of 1 John
and we go to verse three we can read
something similar for this is the love
of God that we keep his Commandments and
his Commandments are not
Grievous so I believe the closer or more
intimate our relationship with Jesus
becomes the more sinful we will actually
appear in our own eyes yet I believe the
more we recognize his love for us the
more it awakens love in us and then we
don't want to do anything that will hurt
our loving savior 1 John 4:19 says we
love him because he first loved us so
his love awakens love inside of us the
more we connect with Jesus in his word
seeing his love for us in his word then
contemplating his love for us personally
the more it draws us to him Jesus said
in John
12:32 and I if I be lifted up from the
earth will draw all men unto me meaning
when we look at our savior giving up his
life on the cross for us it draws us to
him it actually moves us emotionally we
want to do what he's asking us to do
knowing it's because of his love for us
that he's telling us what to do or not
to
do by this shall all men know that
you're my disciples if you have love one
for another when it says all men that
includes us it helps us to realize that
Jonathan so Jonathan these are a couple
of ways to know whether you know Jesus
if you have more love for others and
then you're doing his will and it's
getting
easier you know I say it this way
because I believe that we'll continue to
grow in our love relationship with him
it's not a stagnant thing relationships
aren't stagnant we're either drawing
closer or moving further apart it's like
this with any
relationship are you spending more time
with them enjoying doing what's pleasing
to them or do you hardly ever get
together so that's the same with our
relationship with Jesus and knowing him
that's the key amen very well very very
very good Shelly your fourth question
what does the Bible say regarding the
phrase forgive and forget and this is
coming out of
Australia okay
this I've done a whole sermon on this
but let me just start
here it really is not a Biblical
principle now the Bible does say in
Hebrews 8 and verse 12 God says I will
remember their sins no more when he says
I will not remember their sins we say
Okay God's forgotten but what God means
is if the Bible is indicating God
forgets it means he is not going to take
action on it and when the Bible says God
remembers it means he's springing into
action he's ready to take action think
of Exodus 2 and verse 24 where God heard
the
groaning of the Hebrews and the Bible
says God remembered his Covenant with
Abraham Isaac and Jacob the omniscient
God had not
forgotten but and it's the same with our
sins it's not they are blotted out by
the blood of Jesus God is not going to
take action when we repent his mercy and
his grace Deliver Us now let me talk to
you about
Believers we are repeatedly commanded to
forgive what is human to human
forgiveness well first first let me tell
you what it's not because that's where a
lot of people get hung
up when we are asked to forgive we're
not condoning the sin we're not saying
oh it was okay this offense was okay
we're not forgetting what happened or we
never learn from the experience we're
not guaranteeing that the other person's
going to change their behavior but if
they are unrepented
then what we do is change our Rules of
Engagement to guard ourselves against
repeated injury what forgiveness is not
naively restoring trust trust has to be
earned
reconciliation is the goal of
forgiveness but we can't assume that so
what is forgiveness the Bible tells us
it's an intentional act it's the one who
has been victimized is releasing the
negative feelings and emotions of anger
rage and resentment and we God's love is
the source of our forgiveness he helps
us to see others as the broken people
that they are and to understand that
their fault their offense is a result of
sin forgiveness is the very essence of
our faith and let me say this we are
commanded to choose to forgive it's a
process but it's non-negotiable this is
an act of obedience Jesus told Peter in
Matthew 18:
21-22 forgive 70 time 7 Perfection times
Perfection we're not surrendering to a
person person when we forgive we're
surrendering to God's love and here's
the thing if we don't why does God tell
us to forgive our enemies pray for our
enemies because unforgiveness is like
drinking poison to try to get even with
someone the poison pollutes our emotions
our spirit our life it even it even
uh affects us physically because stress
causes physical illnesses that affect
the heart the mind and the body it
contributes to depression obsessive
behaviors and it even alienates us from
God when you do not forgive someone you
know what happens you get Frozen in a
time capsule of when the offense
occurred
you a resentment and bitterness can grow
in you and it will stifle your spiritual
walk the lord gave me this quick if I
can get it in in this minute I asked him
show me what forgiveness is all about he
showed me a mountain with a stream
coming down to the valley and then a
little wire anchored on either side it
was anchored of this stream and all the
trash coming down the stream when it got
to that wire guess what happened it
collected piece by piece and what
happens it built up a dam so the water
could no longer flow and the Lord said
that's what unforgiveness is like in our
heart if we have unforgiveness in our
heart all the trash comes and collects
around that and the Living Water of the
Holy Spirit can no longer flow through
you amen a great great amen great great
illustration there Shelly thank you very
much we want to just take a uh
quick address roll and then we'll be
right back and just kind of see if we
got any additions to the questions that
we had is it fair enough sounds good
sounds great sounds
good if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each month
they will bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org 75 be sure to include your name
and where you live and then watch 3 Aban
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word
welcome back is there any final uh
comments I think James I'd like to talk
about that question you know saved by
grace judged by works uh Colossians 1
didn't get a chance to share this but
Colossians 1 1-6 really good verses uh
Paul there is talking about how we are
saved by the grace of God in fact he
says Grace and peace be unto you through
uh our father and the Lord Jesus Christ
in verse two and then he goes on to talk
about the faith of God's people since
you've heard we've heard of your faith
in Jesus Christ so you've got Grace and
you've got faith and then he talks about
the love that they have to all the
Saints and the hope they have uh uh laid
up in heaven uh because they've heard
the word of truth and the gospel but
then he says which is verse six which is
come unto you as it is in all the world
and bring BRS forth fruit as it does
also in you since the day that you heard
it and knew the grace of God in truth
knew the grace of God in truth to know
the grace of God in truth produces fruit
so our works can never save us only the
perfect life and the penalty satisfying
substitutionary death of Christ saves us
and that is by grace through faith yet
those who are saved by grace through
faith bring forth the fruit of good good
works that are ordained of God according
to Ephesians 2: 8-10 again so these God
ordained Works testify to the genuiness
of our Salvation it's so important for
us to understand this balance we can
never be saved by our works we're always
going to be saved by grace through faith
but that grace through faith produces
good works amen amen amen anything else
guys well I just want to thank you for
those questions it was a blessing may
help me to study more and be able to
answer your questions thank you for
questions I'm just thinking that you
know our Salvation is righteousness by
faith both imputed righteousness where
his righteousness is credited to us but
then the infused righteousness when
Christ dwells in our hearts by faith
through the holy spirit amen just want
to take this opportunity to thank each
one of you you're special to us we love
you God bless you have a wonderful rest
of the day
[Music]